vidéo hot bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoints dans la matinale de rtl france
alors dans quelques heures on le disait
manuel macron va recevoir les
partenaires sociaux avec comme échanges
impossible la réforme des retraites
est ce que vous vous craignez une
accélération du calendrier du chef de
l'état sur ce sujet écoutez oui un petit
peu puisque les annonces aussi bien du
chef de l'état que du ministre de
l'économie et des finances vont un petit
peu dans le sens en disant bon on n'aura
peut-être pas à faire la réforme telle
qu'on l'avait prévu au départ mais il
faut envisager une mesure paramétrique
autrement dit le recul de l'âge de la
retraite ce qui évidemment ont pour eux
serait un moyen d'équilibrer les
finances mais qui sait parfaitement
injuste à l'égard des futurs retraités
puisque en gros ça revient à leur dire
ben vous travaillent plus longtemps au
je rappelle quand même que chez les
ouvriers
la durée de vie je dirai après la
retraite est beaucoup moins grande que
chez les cadres et que de ce point de
vue-là ça revient à dire que leur temps
passé à la retraite sera écourtée qui
est donc profondément injuste et qui en
plus économiquement n'est pas nécessaire
puisque on a eu il ya peu de temps le
rapport du conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui a bien expliqué que
finalement oui certes il y avait un
manque de cotisation du fait de la crise
sanitaire mais que finalement la
situation financière n'était pas aussi
grave que ça et que les choses devaient
s'améliorer assez rapidement donc je
vois pas pourquoi il y a urgence
aujourd'hui annoncer de nouvelles
mesures mesures pardon si ce n'est qu'
on veut envoyer un signal politique à la
banque centrale européenne et à la
commission européenne pour leur dire
d'écouter voilà on prend des mesures
on va tailler dans le social pour en
quelque sorte justifier les subventions
reçues de la banque centrale européenne
pour la crise du coc vide
c'est donc essentiellement un signal
politique mais c'est aux touristes aussi
assigné
le parfaitement injuste à l'égard de
l'ensemble des recettes et je rappelle
que le candidat macron avait dit que
pendant son mandat ils n'augmenterait
pas la durée de cotisation et ne
reculerait pas l'âge de la retraite
alors néanmoins pour rendre acceptable
le départ à la retraite l'exécutif
penserait un coup de pouce aux petites
retraites aux personnes ayant une
carrière hachée notamment les femmes ou
les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler très jeune est ce que dans
ces conditions où seriez plus ouvert
mais écoutez je voudrais quand même
rappeler que le système actuel donne
déjà à des coups de pouce aux chômeurs
aux femmes ayant eu des enfants et que
d'une manière générale il y à des minima
sociaux aussi bien d'un régime de base
que dans la gym complémentaires qui font
que l'on bonifie en quelque sorte les
carrières incomplètes ou haché et puis
deuxièmement ce que disent certains en
matière de compensation n'engagent
qu'eux-mêmes parce que pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de projet sur la table
d'ailleurs on y tient pas et les
promesses que c'est bien connu
n'engagent que ceux qui les reçoivent
alors en tout cas tous les partenaires
sociaux aujourd'hui sont opposés à un
projet de réforme mais avant la
présidentielle de 2000 22 selon vous
est-ce que le débat doit avoir lieu quoi
qu'il arrive après la présidentielle
un débat on peut toujours en avoir les
organisations syndicales et en
particulier la mienne ont des
propositions pour essayer d'améliorer
les systèmes de retraite et on peut
parfaitement en parler calmement mais
annoncer le grand soir des retraites et
ensuite dire venez vous asseoir à la
table des négociations
non ça ne marchera pas d'ailleurs c'est
pas du tout ce que dit emmanuel macron
en gros il propose la mesure
paramétrique type c'est à dire le recul
de 62 à 64 ans ce qui n'est qu'une
accélération est ce qui est déjà prévu
d'ailleurs et que nous contestons
d'ailleurs tout autant
je vous rappelle que c'est le calendrier
mais en place par le gouvernement
précédent que emmanuel macron veut
simplement accéléré et comme il était
dans le gouvernement
pressé d'en bas il sait parfaitement de
quoi il parle non très franchement si
c'est pour aborder les choses avec
quelques petites mesurettes pour faire
passer la pilule
ça ne marchera pas un mot bienne
négociations de fond mais on ne veut pas
dire un échange sur le comptoir pour
simplement faire passer la pilule en
attendant bien sûr de remettre ça sur le
tapis
alors si on accepte ça maintenant bien
ce serait une brèche en quelque sorte
dans le système alors certains je pense
notamment à françois bayrou prône à
référendum à référendum sur la question
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bah écoutez il faudrait que monsieur
albert ou écrivent la question qu'il
propose
je pense que je serai très intéressant
etes-vous pour l'amélioration du système
des retraites tout le monde est pour
etes-vous pour travailler plus longtemps
là je suis pas sûr que il aurait un très
grand succès merci beaucoup
didier d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin dans la matinale de rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes secrétaire
général adjoint de l'union confédérale
des retraités de force ouvrière